well dw's chief international editor
richard walker has been speaking with
china's chaje de faire in uh germany
zhang joong hwa about his country's
reaction to nancy pelosi's visit
thank you very much for speaking with
deutsche weller
china's announced large military
maneuvers around taiwan
in response to nancy pelosi's visit
there
can you please explain why china is so
angry about this visit
before i answer your question i want to
point out what miss pelosi has done with
her visit to taiwan
this also undermined the political basis
of our relations and undermined chinese
territorial integrity and sovereignty
and
territorially integrated and also very
intent and by doing so she also
endangered peace and security in the
taiwan strait and the whole region
has sent a fatal a wrong signal to the
independence forces
you can understand the measures that we
apply to stop these separatists
to defend our sovereignty
but also to dissuade the americans from
the wrong course
there is also a precedent in 1997 newt
gingrich was in taiwan
there was not such a big reaction from
beijing back then
china reacted in a much more relaxed way
about what consequences her trip had
we have also observed increasing support
from the americans
so you can understand why we reacted so
strongly to this visit
why react militarily why not just stay
the diplomatic course
you know we have prepared militarily
precisely against the increasing
independence efforts
i also want to emphasize that in
addition to these routine maneuvers
we will also take economic and political
measures
but beijing could permanently defuse the
situation by promising that china will
never achieve unification with taiwan by
force
why doesn't china make such a promise
that would permanently calm the
situation
we have said from the very beginning
that we will put all our efforts towards
a peaceful reunification
but the growing activity of the
independence movement has made this
impossible
we have to be prepared we have to
respond to this
much
the military actions the maneuvers were
only directed against the independence
activists
against that movement
not against the chinese people on the
island of taiwan
sdw's international editor richard
walker talking with china's sharje de
faire in berlin
well joining us now is valerie tan she's
an analyst with the mercator institute
for china studies here in berlin welcome
to dw um you've written that the timing
of nancy pelosi's trip to taiwan is
particularly sensitive to xi jinping and
china's top leadership just explain to
us why that is
well this year is particularly sensitive
for xi jinping because he is seeking a
third term as the
leader and the chief of chinese
communist party party state essentially
so the last thing he wants is to appear
weak or undermined not least by the
united states and it's beyond just this
year going ahead to 2049 he has made
reunification with taiwan a historic
mission and part of the greater goal of
the greater rejuvenation of the chinese
nation so
for
c pelosi's pelosi's visit requires a
strong chinese response if not he will
come across as weak
right and so
so a lot of these um these belligerent
pronouncement that's been for domestic
consumption
yes to a certain extent um
two ways to look at it first on one hand
it is obviously to drive up nationalism
and militaristic further obviously the
first of august which was the
anniversary founding anniversary of the
people's liberation army also played a
huge factor here so the mood is still
quite
high when it comes to like nationalism
and anything related to that so
particularly with taiwan which most
chinese and china do consider as part of
chinese territory but that said though
there is definitely a silent majority
within china who would be against the
idea of a military invasion or a
full-blown war over taiwan right
so it as ever with these things it's
complicated so we had a relationship
between the united states and china that
was already fraught
has this trip moved that in one way well
certainly hasn't made it friendly has it
has has it actually made it worse
well i'm not really a china u.s
relations expert but i can definitely
say one thing with or without pelosi's
visit relations between china and taiwan
have already hit a historic low so
obviously
her trip to taiwan does little to
improve or repair cross-street relations
but that said it really sets the stage
for how bilateral relations between
china and taiwan are going to proceed
from now onwards we're going to see more
militarization we're going to see an
increase in intensity and frequency of
economic coercion
increasingly that will be the norm for
how beijing treats taiwan
the question right now is can it get any
worse for now what we've seen is china
is also quite careful not to overstep
its show of anger as it will also have
to bear some if not most of the
consequences if a full-blown military
conflict does happen taiwan's
independence movement seems to be quite
a concern for china and
is it really strong there what are they
doing
i think what we've seen in this visit is
within taiwan's leadership they have
been careful to play down the visit and
if you have followed like what taiwan
said during her speech
this morning
in the joint press conference that she
helped with nancy pelosi the word
independence or declaration of
dependence was not really openly put
across because they know that would
signal or that would be a clear
indication for china to really take
action instead the visit and what taiwan
said and top taiwanese and egypt have
been going around using this narrative
of protecting their system protecting
sovereignty and it's run on this
values-based
idea of freedom democracy human rights
so those are the really key values or
beliefs that taiwan is really fighting
for the whole idea of protecting
democracy and sovereignty understood
thank you that's very clear thanks for
joining us valerie tan from the mercator
institute for china studies thank you